when we were working on this film we
talked a little bit about music and I
said my number one choice would be Hans
Zimmer I sent in this little taste of
the movie and he absolutely loved it and
he was like okay I'm in let's do it
worked with Hans and Steve mazzaro was a
very moving experience you go here we go
we're gonna see some little genius
moment happen
he'll just play different combinations
and maybe it goes I know maybe about
maybe maybe there's a little things will
happen and you'll see him go into this
little Zone doing something incredible
Joshua take care of her
one of my favorite pieces of music in
the film there's this conversation
between Joshua and Alfie and musically
it has to all be doing complementary and
contrasting things no
[Music]
we're just saying we can't go to heaven
because we're not good
and I'm not a person
the most important thing to me also to
hands is Emotion music encourages you
pulls you in a certain direction
emotionally what Hans is doing in the
film just go straight into the soul what
do you want sweetie
to be free
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign